all right I'm on less familiar ground
here
so what I'm holding is the Jabulani I
think that's how it's pronounced I hope
that's how it's pronounced official
match ball for the World Cup which is
cause very many people and very many
players a great great deal of pain so I
feel a bit of a fraud talk about
football because I was the stereotypical
nerd at school interested in music
interested in computer games interested
in computer programming too new type of
football ball football that was
introduced for for the World Cup in fact
a number of different clubs have been
using it for example the Germany German
Bundesliga but it's the official ball of
the off of the World Cup and the problem
is very many players are having great
difficulty in controlling it in fact
some of them have said that it behaves
as if the supernatural is controlling it
they can't they really can't handle it
in simple terms a ball going through the
air you can imagine it as a book of
boo-boos Ayla sorry
it's simple terms a ball game pedia you
can imagine it's ball with the air
flowing smoothly around it but that's
really too simple because the reality of
the situation is that the ball causes
drag as it passes through the air and so
what you see is you see the air spread
out
and instead of going smoothly around it
goes straight on and then you get
turbulence behind the ball and that's
that's Bragg what we're going to have to
do to try and dig out and understand
just why it's so difficult to control is
get into what turns out to be the really
really difficult area of fluid mechanics
hydrodynamics and how that relates to
two objects moving it moving in a fluid
turbulence is behind the ball in its
past why is it still affecting the ball
ah well because of conservation of
momentum
so what drag there is on the ball the
energy for that and the momentum for
that have to have come out of the ball
okay so it's basically Newton's laws of
physics that slowed a ball down as its
passing through the air the interesting
thing about this when you first look at
it it's not like a traditional football
it doesn't have the 20 hexagons or 12
Pentagon's which is the standard
Buckminster ball which has been used for
quite some time it's it's got a much
more sort of smoother appearance much
more molded I guess than the standard
ball and also it has these rims and
these ridges all over it we've got an
object
luckily in this case is quite it's quite
spherical and it's moving through a
fluid and I generally think of fluids as
being liquids but the air is actually a
fluid and what forces are in this on
this ball well obviously this was forced
downwards due to gravity but there's
also it's moving through air if air
wasn't there we didn't have air
resistance this was just all true we
didn't have any friction at all in the
ball it would just continue for infinity
but a ously we have air and that acts
that puts a drag force on the board
what's what's what we're seeing in this
World Cup were seeing two things in this
world cup I think primarily apart from
swerve which we're not seeing him
throughout Cup we're seeing the ball
going too far
and I think you can attribute that to
two things firstly this ball has been
designed to have less drag so the
players aren't used to that and it's
catching them by surprise the ball is
traveling through the air it's going a
lot further and that's especially with
England you're seeing the motor hitting
the ball a lot the key thing is just how
the ball moves through the air and
importantly how the air moves past the
ball so we've got two different regimes
really one of which is called laminar
flow and laminar flow is where you get
nice smooth stream lines going across
the board the ball goes through through
the air and what what you end up with a
very very smooth passage of the ball but
in fact for balls moving and any sort of
velocity comparable to that you have in
a game of football soccer of that
persuasion then it's in fact what you
get is turbulent flow the other thing
you're seeing is that this ball is
bouncing and we've just had a kick
around and it's like a power ball it's
unbelievable you touch it and it just
goes bringing up and the reason for that
is because it's got a high coefficient
of restitution right essentially means
it's just a very elastic ball if you
like if you take a ball you can drop it
and the height that it bounces back to
the ratio of the height that you drop it
and the height that it bounces back to
is its coefficient of restitution this
ball bounces back about 70% of the way
the important thing is that as you as
the the ball moves through the owners in
this turbulent flow regime you get
little Eddie's of unfortunate Bonelli's
law point and very important law which
basically relates pressure and and speed
so the higher the
speed the lower the pressure and so if
you if you have this ball moving through
the air you getting these these Eddie's
these vortices set up your chin to the
velocity but you're also changing the
pressure those things are coupled
together and so what you can do if you
if you change that turbulent flow you
clear with that turbulent flow then what
you can do is you can adjust the
pressure on different on different sides
of the board if you put spin on the
board you can also adjust that pressure
difference and that is how you control
the ball that's how you move it make it
move different directions football is
that traditionally the smartest people
in the world are you saying they
understand laminar and turbulent it's
remarkable how they I am sure that they
don't what's them sure that some of them
might understand but I'm sure that the
majority probably don't understand
laminar and turbulent flow pretty
certain I don't understand laminar
turbulent flow but it's room are what is
remarkable is that that's simply by
practice and through training
footballers have sort of embedded all
this physics knowledge by intuition and
can bend the ball as almost at will the
best camp so this new ball
the difficulty is because it's been
changed and because it's been made more
aerodynamic and in fact it has been made
more aerodynamic and in fact look for a
university which like Nottingham is an
East Midlands spent a lot of time and
effort I think six years really working
on on this board but the difficulty is
of course is that the players then have
to take is have to somehow take account
of this without knowing all the details
physics of course in terms of how this
thing flies and so that's that's you
have to unlearn basically your control
of the ball and and and really learning
a completely different way of
controlling it moreover the working
though the playing in a very different
environment in terms of atmospheric
pressure and that will also affect how
the ball plays how it will affect how
they you have this crossover between
turbulent and laminar flow it will
affect how the ball spins all of which
depend on just how it's simple it seems
simple but it's very important it's very
very tricky down at eyes just how the
air flows across the board
it's these effects it's the lack of drag
it's the bounciness of the ball and to a
certain extent but really not very much
it's the altitude that they're playing
at on occasion because obviously at
higher altitude the air stinner the ball
drags less okay so this is a really
simple I thought was a really neat demo
that I saw
I saw on the Internet and therefore I've
nicked it I've stolen it so what we have
here is we're just going to show an
effect called the Magnus effect which
shows how simply by putting spin on a
ball you can control how it actually
moves through to the N again what it's
do what I'm not going to go into the
details exactly how this works but the
important thing is that by controlling
the velocity the speed of air at
different positions of the ball then you
control the pressure and by controlling
the pressure then you can get it to go
up and go down and do very many
different things what you want to really
look out for is that as I as I pull this
and let release it you should see the
ball move up in the air to get some lift
upwards due to the fact that it's
spinning so let's try it yeah that
didn't work too bad that was really cool
so what was happening to what I did
there was just by wrapping the elastic
band around it and then releasing what
you do is you put spin on that so this
is traveling through the air but there's
also a layer of air which is basically
coupled to the to the cops and so as
that's moving around we've got the air
coming it's going against air here so on
one side what you have is that this
copper layer is moving with the air flow
and sorry with the air flow and the
other side is moving against the airflow
and what that does is that creates a
pressure difference and so what you can
do from self pressure difference you
create a greater pressure here then here
you lift it up